welcome to Table Talk my name is Brett
pastor at the table at church in Sachse
Texas and today I want to unpack one of
the weirdest things about human beings
namely that we constantly longed to be
wherever we aren't the way the Catholics
st. Francois do Sal put it is he said in
company we sigh for solitude and in
solitude we long for conversation in
short it's never good enough whatever
season we're in not a good enough season
whatever day we are living today or at
least it's not as good as like that last
day my man idea we had a while back like
that that was the best day or you know
that day coming up oh that's gonna be
the that's gonna be a great day and then
what happens you get to that day and
you're like hmm
Wow sort of hoping for something
different you know maybe it's the next
day we long to be where we are not I
remember a few years ago I was still in
seminary and I was just very busy and I
had almost no time to read what I wanted
to read my reading list was dictated to
me my by my classes I'm a nerd and so
that's like really annoying and I was
that season I was in or that class I was
in it's not my favorite class and that's
the books are not my favorite books and
so I remember I'm at the library local
library and I'm studying for this class
and I'm looking at the shelves up on
shelves of books and I'm longing I mean
I'm dying again I'm a nerd
to have the freedom to to read what I
want so fast forward a year or so and I
graduated and I was free free to read
whatever I wanted it was time and so I
go to the library and I choose this
particular book a book I'd really been
eyeing for a while and really like oh I
couldn't wait
and so with passion I dove in and within
a few pages I just wasn't quite as
interesting you know as I kind of hoped
and I found myself thinking huh I don't
really feel like reading this sort of
want to read something different
remember that one class ahead seminarian
like the books for that class like huh
they're so good though
those are the days huh a few months ago
I went on a person retreat and in the
days leading up to it all I wanted was
to be on that retreat
I mean people people were exhausting
conversations just dragged on and I just
needed some time away like that would be
the key to all of my problems so I get
on the retreat and within a few hours
what happened you guessed it I was at
home like with my friends my family like
those were the good times that what on
earth is wrong with us
so psychologists and theologians they'll
tell you that this the sense of
dissatisfaction with the present moment
is a key reason that we are chronically
unhappy in st. Francois he goes on to
point out that the problem from a
spiritual standpoint is actually much
more grave he says that this chronic
dissatisfaction is actually a form of
disobedience to God why because it's God
who orders our steps in our days in our
lives not in some weird deterministic
stance like he's just moving the chess
pieces of your life but but in a but in
the sense of God is like he's with you
and for you and right the life you have
is his will and so what we are saying is
- God is not good enough so whether it's
the fussy baby driving you crazy or that
new position at work that you thought
would solve all your problems but it
seems instead to have simply given you a
new set of problems the answer is
probably not like running away from it
not not longing for better days but
simply taking a deep breath embracing it
learning to be grateful for the moment
the day the life that God has given you
that's a key step on the path to
becoming happier more mature more
life-giving person that's all for today
if you enjoyed this video please like it
share it comment and you can subscribe
to my youtube channel or - basically -
on any podcast
form by searching bretzel furred table
talking grace in peace